Jezz and this is our nod and we have
from Facebook to talk about abstract
interpretation today so I've been at
Facebook working on the last three years
for on engine optimization and we've
used abstract interpretation
interpretation extensively in the
process so I manage the co compilers
team at Facebook so we build the
infrastructure for compiler tool chains
in particular all the sputtering engine
that the J's will describe right now
so today we'll cover what abstract
interpretation is how and why Sparta is
being used at Facebook how Spyder is
fast and therefore why you might want to
use it and finally we go over some
examples on how you can use it so at
Facebook we have many large Android apps
the need to run on all kinds of devices
from high end devices to low-end devices
such optimization it's highly important
and since we are dealing with large apps
the optimizer is definitely efficient
otherwise you're just replacing slow run
time to slow compile times so the two we
use for optimizing is called read X
which takes next byte code which runs on
Android and makes it smaller and faster
now let's talk a bit about what it means
to optimize something so we want to make
a program smaller and faster while
preserving its observable behavior and
to do that we need to be able to have a
model of what its behaviors and that is
where abstract interpretation comes in
so in a nutshell semantics are what
kinds of behavior program here exhibit
and we want to be able to model all of
them now we can possibly simulate every
single possible execution of a program
because obviously there will be carrying
complete as such we map concrete values
such as integers and to more general
abstract values such as intervals and by
representing more concrete States with
many complete sets of 1 abstract state
the problem becomes more feasible and
then we simulate program execution and
interpreter using these abstract values
until we reach a fixed point
so let's look at a sign domain for a
first example the same domain enables us
to answer questions like does this
function return a value that's always
greater than zero there's a returning
value that's ever now and so every
element in the abstract domain
represents one or more concrete values
in this case our concrete values are
integers and their trap values are
simple intervals so note that some
extract rarely some more general than
others by more general I mean that one
can represent all the values of the
other and more so in this example it's
that pointer yes so in this example the
domain that says all elements greater
equal to zero and converse us both the
domain of zero and domain of elements
strictly greater than zero
as such we place a higher on the diagram
every abstract domain must also have a
top and bottom value topic it's actually
encompasses all possible values and it's
another way of saying we have no idea
what actual value this thing holds at
runtime bottom represents no possible
value usually arises in the context of
dead code detection because if a program
never executes a sudden block then none
of the values another the variables that
assign any values so now demonstrate how
we can use these abstract values to
model programs execution on the left
hand side is a piece of code we step
through and on the right hand side we'll
show the state of the program after each
corresponding line is executed so on the
first line we simply have a go 0 on a
second line we assigned b1 but there is
no abstract domain representing exactly
one however we do have the next best
thing which was that B is strictly
greater than 0 now we go to the F block
where B gets assigned 0 that's pretty
straightforward but now the 6 the next
question is what happens after we exit
the F block so we need a way to
represent the value of B and we have no
idea whether the F block was taken or
not
so we can look at the diagram and look
at the next most general value that
encompasses both values of B so it's
right above zero and greater than equal
to zero
sorry it's really greater than zero and
we get this so for an X's our example
will progress into more general
intervals I'll point out first that sign
domains are very simple intervals and
you can rewrite the earlier domain like
this I won't go into the exact diagram
of the interval domain because it's it
has many elements and it's a lot of
taken but in short all valid or possible
domains are valid abstract values and we
are going to use the interval domain to
illustrate what it means to I to rate to
a fixed point so here we have a very
simple loop that increments an integer
we want to know at the end of the loop
what possible values can I take so our
abstract interpreter it's going to step
through this now on the first line since
we initialize a to zero is simply the
interval it contains just the rope now
we add one to it and then inside the
blue body it becomes the interval that
contains just one now we go back to the
top of the loop because we don't know if
we can insert it yet and so we look at
the last value of a and a new value of
eight so the new value of a encompasses
both the previous value zero and the
value in the body of the loop which is
one so a is now spanning from 0 to 1 and
we repeat the process as you might
expect a now you know goes from 0 to 2
and so on and so forth but eventually
this terminates so when we reach a from
0 to 9 note that in the loop body a is
still going to be from 0 to 8 because we
know that the loop body is only entered
when a is less than 9 as such the next
time we go back to the loop head we see
that a hasn't changed and now we know
that a fixed point and we have done with
our analysis of the loop
so that's a very high-level overview of
how I strike interpretation works and
now we're going to talk about how we can
make it fast so for those of you who are
familiar with classic data flow analysis
this fixed-point thing is also being
done but usually they are they do a
simple strategy of iterating over all
basic blocks until we hit that fixed
point that means that any change in a
single basic block causes the entire
method to be reanalyzed over and over
and that's not very efficient so really
what we want to do is to I to the
innermost loop Spurs and then Ultimo's
loops and finally the entire method and
to do that we need to decompose the
graph the control flow graph into these
loops and so we use this thing called
bohdanka our item for that I won't go
into the details but conceptually it is
titrant strongly connected components
algorithm applied recursively so every
time we detect a small strongly
connected component we pretend that is a
single node and then we search for the
next largest SCC that contains it and by
doing this because of Lee we eventually
get all the loops of the program I'll
also add that soon spot I would have a
parallel implementation of this what
this means is that instead of iterating
through the blocks serially we can break
a program into individual loops and
analyze them in parallel this makes
things even faster than ever ideas the
next optimization I'm going to talk
about is Patricia trees so in the
example earlier the loop you saw that we
needed to store the value of a at the
loop header and more generally we know
when we hit a fixed point we need to
start the program State and every basic
block now this is very expensive since
the program can have many basic blocks
and be very large so hash tables are
common choice for for representing these
mappings
look up as fast and it's alright for
small programs but follow as I said for
large programs
this is gonna be inefficient cuz they're
gonna copy the hash table over and over
for every basic block and the thing is
that most program states are going to be
similar every basic block is probably
going to modify maybe two or three
variables but it may be you know dozens
or hundreds of variables per method but
fortunately since most program states
are similar we can take advantage of
this we can store only the differences
between the states and using immutable
petrified trees so here's a diagram of
one such tree so the keys of this tree
this tree are integers and the values
can be anything you like so in this case
the integers are representing the
register numbers and here we are looking
at an environment that binds register
five to the string food now suppose we
wanted to change five to bind bar so
this shows the environment that does
that and the gray notes are the newly
allocated notes so notice that we only
need to allocate new notes on a spine of
the tree and we can share all the other
notes with the other environment what
this means is that copying a potential
tree is effectively free if you don't
modify it and when you do modify it
it's only a lock the total number of
bindings on the tree so
I'll point out that not every app is
large enough to war on using trees so
small apps might actually benefit from
hash tables but fortunately Sparta makes
it easy to switch between different data
structures so in fact when we X first
implemented its register allocator a
hash table was faster for likeness
analysis but one year later due to
growth side in app size and optimization
complexity this was no longer true
fortunately it only took us four lines
to move from a hash table to a pack
treasure tree this is because bada
provides very clear abstractions over
the concepts of abstract petition and
implementations em this move resulted in
a 90% reduction in memory and a 60%
reduction in running time which is huge
all right now I'm gonna head over to a
node what's going to talk about widening
thanks Jason
so coming back to our previous example
with with this with this truth so you
might think that ok but also
interpretation there's nothing evenly so
magical about it if you have a loop you
essentially go over all iteration of the
loop and you will eventually hit the the
white to white interval the white loop
invariant so what if the loop has a huge
bound you can't actually go go on
forever so fortunately absolutely
protection is goes a little bit beyond
that and the theory provides the the
ability to make big jumps so if you've
seen that that lattice of sign and the
release of generalized interval
intervals that jazz
just jot is quite the true lattice is
very large and in fact it's even it's
even infinite and the idea here is to
make some to take some big strides in
the lattice so when you see it's not
after few iterations is not converging
let's make a big jump and then what
absolute interpretation guarantees is
that after a finite finite sequence of
Big John's you will eventually converge
to a fixed point so in this case the the
most basic way denia one could imagine
is after few iterations it's not stable
so let's let's make your jump to the top
of the lattice and so in this case so we
had the interval 0 9 okay is taking too
much time let's widen to the top and at
the next iteration so our inventors
thought that was quite being all
possible integer values we go through
the loop one more time it still remains
top because incrementing all possible
integers gives us the set of all
possible intervals integers again then
with witched
a fixed point so that's a way to get the
analysis to terminate even though we
have arbitrarily complex loops but then
you might think okay that's very nice
but top doesn't give us much information
it could be all possible integers and
that loop seems pretty simple and in
fact absent depilation
provide provides you with the way of
getting the white the white level of
position because once you wish the fixed
point with with the widening you can
keep going on
you can keep on arising the loop and
getting more precise results so if you
see here that we reach the top during
the iteration with widening now that we
can do we can analyze the loop again and
when we enter the loop we know that a is
less than
Nigel and night on over then 99 and what
the theory tells us is that the in giant
we obtain is still a correct opposite
sound approximation of all our possible
concrete concrete states so technically
speaking is known your fixed point it's
called a postfix point but basically it
still is still a quite approximation so
we can keep going on and eventually
after a finite number of steps we will
which another fixed point or opposite
fixed point and in this case this is the
actual collect environment which is
which is quite exactly the set of all
possible values the variable can touch
within within the loop so the algorithm
with with with knowing is little more
complex and costly from the
computational aspects it's not
implemented yet in Sparta but it will be
available in the in the future with this
imposter oh when we will provide more
new Michael you know equal abstractions
all right so that's the way that's all
there we very nice but in practice how
do we use Sparta and is it as easy to
use as we claim which I need to be
that's actually the title this of the of
this presentation making absolutely
interposition easy so let's see how do
we call how do we code that that lattice
the lattice of sign so first of all we
just define an enumeration type that
contains all the all the elements all
the symbols in that in that lattice and
then Sparta provides an implementation
for that that is based on the bit
vectors so it's a sophisticated
implementation I will not go over all
the details refer you to the detail be
positive
if you are interested in the in the in
the algorithm but it's a compact and
efficient representation of the other
arrays and so we have the type sign
lattice which is essentially the vault
structure the framework the bit vector
representation of our lattice of that
size with our elements then we need to
encode all those relations in in the in
the lattice so technically it's called a
partial order but all those edges using
the lattice have to be anchor anchor
data so we define that but you're on an
encoding the daiquan in a structure
called SL here how do we do it if I
simple we didn't implement it in a very
decorative way we take each edge in the
diagram and we just added to the to the
structure so button is less general than
less than zero something for for zero
for greater than zero and then we know
that 0 is Legend Award and greater than
equal to greater than or equal to zero
same thing so on and so forth you got a
you know that way so that's that's all
you need to do to implement that data is
and data structure has some particular
properties so it it should satisfy an
above of of constraints and the nice
thing is that this implementation
verifies that those constraints are
actually satisfied so it's not like you
can implement any lattice that doesn't
satisfy those requirements if the
property is abortion you will get a you
get an error when you the program now
now that we have our arrays we need like
a thin whopper
that allows us to to express program
properties using this design artist so
sparta provides the final finite
abstract domain conforto it really takes
any financial at ease and turns it into
a finite abstract domain so it just take
the dll amounts the rata structural the
encoding is a bit vector implementation
of the lattice and the actual diagram
that we just that will just define them
okay so does that defines a sign
property for one variable but we've seen
that our actual program state is
essentially a set of signs that suppose
all the possible signs for all variables
in our program so virtually we need to
define an abstract domain that map's
variables to signs so we can we can do
this using the again the Constructors
provided by a by Sparta we could use a
hash table I suggest is quite or party
shot we so in this case we use the
Patricia button shot we map or abstract
environment and given our poem variables
we map them to the to the sign domain
and what we obtain is the exact the
implementation needed to represent each
program state at each one point and
that's all you need so the code I've
just shown is exactly all you need to
fight to get an efficient implementation
of the synapse on domain okay so that's
how we implement absolute demands police
important now how do we implement
analysis how do we one that abstract
domain over an arbitrary programmer for
this we use a simple abstraction that
essentially a graph so you can see it's
called the poem interface so it's a it's
a general control flow graph with and
when the ordinance if Nevada and and an
edges and it cannot present the
commercial graph of a method or the
entire coal graph of our program and
Sparta is a completely independent from
the poor I mean language architecture
analyzed so you just need to provide a
bridge between that interface and say
your indicate in the case of Windex the
other way by code or it could be an
abstract syntax tree or let's say you
want to analyze the programs you have a
Voyager to the LLVM
internal representation and once you've
implemented internally that Voyager the
last step is to define the analyzer
itself and the analyzer is simply an
instance of a fixed point a tomato so
that the the very complicated algorithm
that will go over the program that will
take your program interface you abstract
the main in this case the the design the
main and automatically go over all nodes
you method or your or your program and
perform the analysis in order to perform
the analysis you have to provide the
semantics of your basic operations of
the statements or how you analyze your
your basic blocks and you have to
implement two two methods analyze node
and analyze addre so in the case of a
control flow graph of a method a node is
a statement or a basic block sequence a
sequence of statements and you have to
go centrally over all possible
statements in your in your in your
language or internal internal
representation and provide the coax
emetics so one example here like if you
you analyze the stepping on that
assign the value 0 to viable what you do
is that you set the variable V which is
the left-hand side of the segment on
that
to the sign the main eqz which is equal
to zero and that's all you have to do so
on and so forth for all your own your
statements and analyze edge is used to
mostly to to analyze the the branches or
the conditionals so when you go from one
node from one node to the other from one
basic block to the other through a
conditional statement you have to
perform some some special attractions so
you have to provide the semantics for
that so for example here we have like a
conditional that test that whether
variable is greater than greater than
zero and in this case when we go to one
node to zero we must ensure that V is
greater than zero it's done by
essentially getting the abstract value
the sign of that variable in the in the
the incoming environment and forcing it
to be greater than zero using the the
meet operation which which is
essentially an intersection in the in
the lattice so whatever the sign was we
intersect it with greater than zero and
in particular if the sign was something
like negative or less than zero the
intersection would be empty would we
turn button so that means that this
branch is unreachable and as jazz
described previously bottom is very
important as a way to detect unreachable
or dead code through two static analysis
to be able to actually statically infer
that a condition is always is always
true or false and that's all you need
so again if you want to see holes
implemented you can look into the lean
tests in Sparta or to have more
sophisticated examples
can we have the code in in Windex and
one example is interprocedural analysis
inter particle separation as a judge
will describe right now all right so so
far our examples are using control flow
graphs and basic blocks but if you saw
the program interface just now we really
only care about graphs in general it
does a care of what kind of notes or
what kinds of edges compose the graph
and therefore we can actually swap out a
control flow graph for a call graph and
get an interpreter analysis and in fact
we axis using justice to implement a
powerful interprocedural constant
propagation optimization I don't have
I'm not going to go into the slice of
those because it's a lot more
complicated but you can find out some
github so spara
is that Facebook and computer slash
spider and redirects is that Facebook /
redirects and we have lots of cool
examples there you guys have any
questions thank you for your attention
[Applause]